[Applaudissements]
et c'est le même ce qu'elle est vraiment
adulte aura alors un oui sauver les
minimes et kabimba venait à côté d'elle
un casting l'avocat bibard a défini télé
le chemin je suis ravi d'apporter
kisimba donc à l'aller n'était pas de
quotidiens après les blessures aux
genoux sur ses genoux khaled est très
mignon suivie d une mignonne un petit
smack carrément akwaaba revenus emmerdes
à l'appel
[Applaudissements]
j'aimerais qu'on se passe tous à 10
points boulangerie je vous rappel quoi
faire gagner une boulangerie faut
qu'elle répondait qu'elle dise c'est
encore ce qu'on d'hanouna pour gagner un
week end à la grande motte et j'enverrai
également que steam bravo c'est parti on
appelle tout de suite et si cette
boulangerie ne répond pas on appellera
une autre boulangerie on est des fous
mais on est quand même mais les
boulangeries sont ouvertes ça sort c'est
qu'on va acheter le pain monsieur alors
on appelle la boulangerie qu'on a dit
avant celle là attention ça ça me met
tout à l'heure